Văn phòng chính phủ và banh hành công văn số bình y hủ chăm linh ba, trên đặt ít kiến chỉ đạo của phó thủ tưởng
từ chức vấn hoa bình về việc nghiên cứu. Để sức sẽ pháp khóc phục những bất cập sau vụ là
tạo vình xanh năm 2018 tại quảng linh. Chứ đó, công thông tin định từ chính phủ đã
tổng hợp thông tin báo chi và dưới lượng liên quan đến vụ việc trong đó nếu só một số lỗ hồng đang
chú ý, tạo được thiết kế cao hơn quyết chọn. Thế yêu thiết bị phát tin hiệu có piểu tự động không có
phẩm báo khi mất kết nối dí phía, thưa điểm sẻ ra tài nạn và tiếp nhận thông tin cách nhau gần thài dự.
Ngoài ra, hiện chứ có cơ chế cảnh báo tự động nếu thuyền viên không kì phát tỷ nhiều khẩn cấp.
Mình cảnh nó, hẹt thông sự báo thời tiết cho tạo dù liệt còn hạn chế, chú ý ua theo bạn tin định kì sau tiến,
chưa đáp ứng yêu cầu cảnh báo dông lúc mất nửa. Các chứ ra để sức sẻ dựng hẹt thông sự báo theo thời gian thực,
tích hợp sữa liệu tự ra ra, vậy tình, phá đau sống và chỉ tự nhiên tạo, chuyên qua các kênh hiện đại giữ dụng gì đâu, về hát em, mà mình tạo.
Phó tụ tướng ra bộ xây dự trụ chính nghiên cứu lỗi dụng nếu trong bài viết, phối hợp các cơ quan lên quan để sức sẻ phát quả lý phụ ở,
báo cao tụ tướng chính phụ trước ngày 15 tháng 30 năm 2020.